ORGANIZATION.
WE'LL SEE WHAT UNFOLDS AS THE T.
KEY ANDRE MILLER, PUCK BLOCKED S
MILLER'S SHOT GOES WIDE.
>> ENERGY SHOULD NOT BE AN ISSUE
AND GOES.
HE'LL DUMP ONE IN.
PLAYED BEHINDENTER.
ERIKSSON, COVERED THE BY KIN
INDICATE GOT IN SPIN-O-RAMA MOVF
ERER GOES
SO STOP BY SCOTT THE
LINEUP.
CHANGES THE WHOLE ELEMENT OFF AS
ABLE TO GET A FACEOFF.
>> SCOTT NET
AND
TROUBA.
MILLER, BROUGHT BACK UP. PLAYEDS
GOT IT. AROUND, NEARLY KEPT B
LOOK AT THIS PASS, RIGHT WITH
OFFENSIVE PENALTIES.
WAS THAT OUT.
KELLER, SPOTS A PLAYER
THROWS A DART OFF THE GLOVE OF
KINKAID, HERE, ENOUGH.
>>E'S FIGHTING
IT, LOOKING WAS A WHOLE LOT OF E
ICE, THAT ISDGEWOOD.
THEY FINALLY DO GET INSIDE
POSITIONY MUCH HAVE A
FULL POWER PLAY HERE.
>> THIS IS PASSING.
A FEW GIVE AND GOES AND
LOOK AT BIG CHRIS
STICK IN FRONT, DEFLECTS IT HIGH
AND WIDE.
STROME HAS AWAY THE FRONT OF
THE NET.
HE'S GOING TO GET